hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
requested a video on Captain Marvel
Kevin Feige recently announced that she
is going to crush the rest of the
Avengers in terms of power levels so
I'll explain what's up with that there's
just been a lot of Captain Marvel stuff
in the news because of what's going on
in the comics and then what's going on
in the movies you know what we should do
if we're actually going to a big Marvel
family photo we should introduce the
newest member of the Marvel family the
newest person joining us Captain Marvel
herself brie Larson
we got the picture recently Kevin Feige
did a really big interview where he
explained Captain Marvel is going to be
their most Opie overpowered character
that they've ever done in a Marvel movie
so far now he was probably not talking
about Thanos or about Odin because the
odinforce makes Odin one of the most
powerful people in the universe next to
things like The Living Tribunal Doctor
Strange shout out or like Thanos when
he's wearing the Infinity Gauntlet we
know we're heading to infinity war it's
likely that Thanos will assemble the
gauntlet so it just makes sense that
she's the most powerful Avengers
character that they've introduced next
to the Hulk because technically the Hulk
would be the most powerful character but
the things the movies have changed is
they've introduced the infinity gems in
ways that they don't appear in the
comics so the vision wields the mind gem
it makes him vastly more powerful than
comic-book vision so the same thing will
probably end up happening with Captain
Marvel there's just very few ways to
make a human character more powerful
than someone wielding an infinity gem so
I'll actually explain because they did
that in the comics before Secret Wars
Doctor Doom did not have an infinity gem
but he was as powerful as someone
wielding an Infinity Gauntlet so that's
kind of another thing but just to talk
about the movies one of the people
that's writing the screenplay Nicole
Perlman she was one of the people
responsible for guardians of the galaxy
getting turned into a movie
she already confirmed that they were
changing captain Marvel's backstory from
the comics so she gets tied up in a lot
of Crees storyline even though Marvel
does have the Kree they appear in the
guardians of the galaxy movie they sound
like they still want to keep the
earth-based Avengers stories separate
from what's happening in the guardians
of the galaxy the Thor movies in outer
space so what will probably happen is is
the Carol Danvers will still be an Air
Force colonel but she will some
how get tied up in the Fuhrer of
infinity war and gain her powers during
that movie via infinity gem recently
during the Civil War two storyline we've
seen her fighting Iron Man but a lot of
you are like what if she were to fight
Thor like there are a lot of characters
that aren't around for her to fight that
could probably put her on her ass Thor
does not have his hammer anymore there's
a female version of Thor it's like a
completely different situation but
technically Thor like forget Odin even
Thor could put comic book Captain Marvel
on her but there's a big twist with
civil war too they still have the final
issue so even though they've changed a
lot of what's going on with the
characters there's a lot of weird Iron
Man stuff happening in the comics right
now just wait til the end of December
beginning of January I'll do a video
explaining Civil War - you know the big
twist behind it but there are a lot of
theories about how Tony Stark is still
around without actually being around
they just want him to seem like he's not
around anymore in the movies what I'm
really hoping for is like a brief moment
if they give her her powers vision style
like he got his powers during Avengers
age of Ultron that was kind of his
origin story hopefully during infinity
war she'll get the same type of
treatment but even in the movies the
odinforce is almost if not more powerful
than at least one infinity gem now
assembling the Infinity Gauntlet is a
different story because even if you have
a gem you're very powerful there's so
many characters that are more powerful
than you but when you combine gems their
effects stack so imagine Doctor Strange
wielding the time gem he's able to
affect time on a relatively planetary
scale still a very very big deal but if
he were to use that with the space gem
he would be able to change time for the
entire universe simultaneously so in the
movies Captain Marvel versus vision
would be a relatively even fight the big
difference there is in what's going on
up in their heads Captain Marvel is
actually an alcoholic just like Tony at
least in the comics I'm hoping they
infuse a little bit of that pathos into
her movie character because one of the
problems with overpower
characters like Superman in the DC
Universe is they need to have some
weakness otherwise it just completely
takes you out of the story if you feel
like they're invincible and there's no
conflict like vision super powerful with
the mind gem but as he explains to
Scarlet Witch he doesn't understand the
gem fully and is kind of fighting it at
times so in the way the mind gem during
the first Avengers film was able to
cloud the minds of lesser beings it also
sounds like vision might have some
similar problems in the other big
problem is that if Thanos is going to
assemble the Infinity Gauntlet then he's
going to have to dismantle vision to do
that really big weakness right there but
the thing is is he's technically
artificial intelligence so you can
separate visions mind from his body his
body can be repaired so he'll be okay
he's like one of those characters that
you could crush into a tin can repair
him later in everything would be all
right you can't really do that with a
human character without some hardcore
medical technology but aside from an
infinity gem there just aren't that many
ways in the movies to make Captain
Marvel more powerful than people like
Thor or the Hulk so in the comics there
were a couple human characters that did
get more powerful than that including
dr. doom like I said during Secret Wars
he became the most powerful character in
the universe for a brief period but the
problem is is the dr. doom is typically
brought down by his own hubris that's a
very dr. doom type thing you know gain
the power that you seek get your
crippled by your own sense of pride the
reason that dr. doom became so powerful
is because he was infused with the
collective power of the beyonders this
extra dimensional race that had the
ability to control the multiverse but
the big twist was is that they only
experienced time in a linear way so dr.
doom was able to travel back along their
timeline and defeat them so power abhors
a vacuum dr. Strange's there with him
and says I don't want all this power I
can't handle it it's too much but dr.
doom who loves power raises his hand
instantly I'll take it so he becomes the
most powerful person in the Marvel
Universe in collects
fragments of all the universes that are
left over and turns that into battle
world so it was a really interesting
epic idea that they'll probably never
get into in the movies we just learned
about the multiverse they haven't told
that many cosmic stories and captain
Marvel's origin in the comics is
relatively cosmic they've changed that
to keep her more earth-based so you can
see like the movies are really trying to
keep it as simple as possible but just
remember when Kevin Feige says that
she's the most powerful character that
they've ever introduced in a movie that
there are characters that are more
powerful than her it's just that they're
leaving off that modifier most powerful
human character you know most powerful
character to come from Earth so there
are a lot of cosmic entities that will
eventually show up in the Marvel movies
we might even see death because she was
a big part of the fan OHS Infinity
Gauntlet storyline so until one of the
other Avengers characters wield the
Infinity Gauntlet in the movies she is
technically the most powerful Avenger
now but let me know in the comments if
Captain Marvel were to throw down with
another Avengers character like they did
in the first Avengers film like we had
Iron Man vs. Thor we had Thor hit
Captain America shield with his hammer
what kind of moment like that do you
want to see with Captain Marvel's
character when she gets her powers I
just feel like there are a couple
characters like Doctor Strange or the
Hulk that she could try to punch
punching is really one of her strengths
she has energy blasts but one of the big
things in the Doctor Strange movie was
that they wanted to get away from people
just standing away from each other
blasting each other with bolts of
lightning so when we see Captain Marvel
fighting what you'll probably see is
something really down and dirty up close
she'll just be wrestling with people
like Hulk or Thanos like Captain Marvel
punching Thanos in the face would be
really awesome and in that way they
might choose to use her like Adam
warlock during the original Infinity
Gauntlet storyline it's just that he was
sort of like the ultimate Avenger during
that so she might become the ultimate
Avenger during the movies but like I
said big difference between the movies
in the comics Captain Marvel in the
comics is kind of like Marvel's version
of Superman but if there any other Marv
videos that you guys want me to do from
the comics or the movies just let me
know in the comments be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll be doing some epic battles videos
in December when a bunch of other TV
stuff goes on break I'll have a bunch of
extra time so there'll be some fun
comic-book stuff happening in the next
month but this weekend there's new rogue
one so I'll do new trailer video for
that next then we have Game of Thrones
and Walking Dead and Westworld on Sunday
so I'll be posting updates on my video
schedule as I roll videos out but rogue
one will be next and I almost forgot
Final Fantasy 15 is coming out next week
too so if you want me to do a story
video for that just let me know in the
comments where you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my
spider-man homecoming carnage video and
you can click here to watch the big
flash arrow legends crossover trailer
again thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys in a couple hours
you